let's start at the beginning how would
this project come to be how did you get
involved with it
sure it seems unusual for you because
you you don't usually do animated films
yeah I'm a producer owner aircraft
pictures which I own with Andrew Rosen
and traditionally we've done mostly
live-action content but on this project
it actually I first became aware of it
about 15 years ago I was on a trip with
a couple of different families and we
were on a bit of a vacation and there
was one little girl who happened to be
coincidentally Parv Anna's age who was
reading the book and after dinner she
asked her mother if she would read aloud
to her and we had a group of about 15
people probably ranging from 9 to like
65 and slowly we all got sucked in said
the story that was being told and it was
a really remarkable experience for me as
an adult because it was the first time
I'd had as an adult that kind of
traditional storytelling experience
where everyone just went silent and just
listened to this mom read your daughter
and over the course of the week after
dinner that became our thing and we read
the entire book that way so really stood
out to me was and really a testament to
Deborah Alice's book and and and how
captivating in the story is and so
wasn't until many years later because I
at that time had just kind of started my
producing career and that meant with the
publisher groundwood books and they to
talk about you know potential books that
they had available and the rights were
available and they pulled out the
breadwinner and I was like oh my god
that's the book that we were so
enraptured with that time so we we
optioned it and and having had an
animation get was thought to be maybe a
live-action it was originally we thought
about doing it as kind of in the vein of
like The Kite Runner and that type of
thing but the book itself is is actually
studying as part of the curriculum and a
lot of kind of sixth grade seventh grade
eighth grade schools classes so we
didn't really want to lose that audience
and we thought if we went The Kite
Runner route it would be a little more
inaccessible and penber
in making it live action you know some
of the scenes would be that much harder
to take and a little harder to introduce
young people to it so we thought if we
went animated and one phrase that Nora
to me the director coined early on was
you know it allows us to kind of sugar
the pill when we're dealing with some of
the harsher realities of the situation
with animation so you know we looked at
animated films that really stood out to
us that had a really strong artistic
point of view and looked at films like
Persepolis and The Secret of Kells which
cartoon saloon had done so they
literally were the first people on our
list and we met with them and and talked
about Co producing the film together and
and they said yes and the rest is kind
of history you guys have made a lot of
music for a lot of movies both
live-action and animation even your
animation stuff's been more the
commercial Pixar and Warner Brothers
kind of thing how did what was the
challenges of this particular story this
required a different sort of thing than
it it definitely did and and when we
first met with Nora she said that you
know the mandate for the music was to in
the same way that the pill was being
sugared story-wise and visually that
musically she really wanted you know
true authentic Afghan music to be part
of this story it's it's their story she
wanted to hear their voices you know but
also to combine that with Western music
and make make that kind of Afghan music
accessible and and emotionally
accessible for Western audiences
audiences internationally it's something
that would help tell the story but
really give us a sense of place so our
big challenge so Jeff Ann and I when we
began our studying of Afghan music and
the great thing about animation is you
have this great lead time so we've
literally were working on it a year
before our final recording so we have on
and off but we had that all that time to
learn
about Afghan music to make our contacts
which ended up to be extremely difficult
because of the Taliban's their mandate
to destroy art basically and destroy
music then in the time that they ruled
Afghanistan and Kabul
they succeeded in wiping out you know
all music schools all schools all
education for girls musicians were
scattered stopped playing so the
tradition kind of got broken in a sense
and it's already a very complicated
tradition because of the tumultuous
history of the land there's kind of this
melange of Persian and Indian and and
then there's all the tribes and they all
have their own kind of music so it was a
real challenge for Jeff and I to kind of
wrap our heads around it get into it and
then to find players and so there's very
few in North America our original plan
was to go to Kabul to record how the
situation had deteriorated badly kind of
kind of last year so we ended up having
to figure out a way to record the those
Afghan instruments remotely and we made
contact with this school in Afghanistan
called the Afghanistan National
Institute of Music
this is a school that was begun in the
days after the Taliban where they not
only teach music but they also teach
girls it's a co-ed school so we were
able to get in work our way into that
kind of world and record remotely the
music shifts a little for the
storytelling sequences right you want to
talk about the difference yeah it was
apparent right away when we saw the film
with Nora the first time that the film
travels down two parallel tracks one is
a real-world as she called it and story
world the beautiful thing is at the end
they merge and they become one and we
understand that the story world
sequences are all explaining the subtext
for real world spoke we realized that
there we needed a slightly different
approach for both those things as we
move forward in the film so real world
was a little more prosaic sombre
stripped-down not as big an ensemble not
as
floral and approach nor even had this
thing where she didn't want us to finish
any the exposition of any of the themes
in the first two reels she said you've
written these beautiful themes now I
only want to hear half of it when we
first meet parwana
which was new for us we you know we'd
never sort of done it she's I could cut
it off halfway like her story's not done
I don't want the music story done which
was an interesting approach and it
worked out quite well but so that was
this sort of truncated and small sound
for real world and then store will
conversely very colorful even more the
Afghan sounds and players followed it
closer to picture a little bit more of
the animated style of scoring because
there's some gymnastics and and some a
lot of fun going on in those those
popping store world scenes and then they
come to slowly you know store well gets
a bit darker as the story goes on real
world gets a bit bigger as she goes to
find she goes to the prison and then it
comes all together right there at the
end let's talk about the director who
isn't here with us today
Norah how was she selected I know that
cartoon saloon is a relatively new
studio right relatively it took ten
years or more I guess and they made two
features yeah their previous two
features were the Secret of Kells and
song at the scene which were directed by
Tom Moore one of the producers here yes
so how did how did Nora get involved
with this sure well the the great thing
about cartoon saloon is they're you know
their studio artists the three
principals Paul Young Tom Moore and
Norah to me all come from animation
backgrounds and artists themselves so it
was never really set up to be just a
vehicle for Tom's work so in this
instance we when we approached cartoon
saloon we talked about you know the
story and kind of where we wanted to do
with it and Nora I guess it got in the
book and had gone home and read it in
one night because she was just she was
so captivated by the story and and what
she could do with it or mind was racing
and so she came back and pitched us all
on this idea of her directing and and
how she would do it and everything and
it was pretty unanimous decisions just
that she was going to be the ones to do
it so you're hoping everyone people
around
world families will see this movie and
can you speak to that like what you hope
they'll they'll get out of it because
there's a lot you can get out of this
movie you can you learn about the
experience of this family but but you
know also about the world and there's so
much you can talk about yeah I mean for
I know that you know we never set out to
do a movie with a message or a political
film or anything like that Nora was
always very adamant about you know this
is a young girl's story it's about her
it's about her family it's about you
know getting her father back
you know universal themes that everyone
can relate to and it's been really
rewarding seeing different people watch
the film and you know a lot of Afghan
people have watched the film and nothing
but praise for I hope is the more people
see it you know the more it broadens
this discussion and adds kind of a
counter-argument this is me personally
speaking like just to some of the
arguments out there now for against
diversity you know in this world so you
know we always welcome the chance to do
much of what was just there musically
and to take an opportunity with a
musical culture like Afghanistan to
bring into the spotlight a little bit
the music and the musicians that don't
usually get certainly in a Hollywood
censor and in US large scope sense a
real fair look and there's some amazing
and beautiful music all over the world
that's rarely heard so this was a great
opportunity for us to bring forth music
musicians particularly we're excited to
work with the this choir Mike alluded to
that dr. SAR mast knew about these
little girls who were part one as age
that we got to record from us just a
small school choir they weren't pros it
doesn't sound like an Anglican Church
Choir you know it's not beautiful but
it's just the perfect rough-hewn sound
for our film and that was a session we
did via Skype in the middle of the night
for us
it was during Ramadan for them so they
were fasting and they had to keep
sitting down so it was it was kind about
was one of those moments you talk about
what what's different about it in this
the score is really to be able to raise
their culture up a little bit into the
spotlight was we were grateful to be
able to do that
yeah and it's a privilege to be
to work on a film that just you know if
we have any hope it's it's that we all
on this planet develop a sense of
empathy and understanding for other
people and this film is so personal it's
a personal story and people it's not
people over there it's it's a your it's
a family and with challenges that you
you can relate to when you see them in
this film so it was such a privilege for
us to be able to work on something that
really you know has such a positive
ability to impact people and and build
that bridge and musically that was
something that was really important to
us that we do bring east and west
together like that I want to thank all
you guys amazing movie